En los últimos tiempos los encuentros entre
el Presidente de los Estados Unidos y los
líderes europeos, y…. también, claro,
el primer ministro de Canadá, Justin Trudeau,
se han vuelto bastante tensos.
La cumbre de la OTAN celebrada a principios
de julio de 2018 ha sido buena prueba de ello…
y ha dejado sobre la mesa algunas preguntas:
¿Tiene razón Donald Trump cuando critica
a sus socios europeos?
¿Están los países europeos de la OTAN aprovechándose
del ejército de los Estados Unidos?
Y tal vez la más importante de todas: ¿Debería
crearse un ejército europeo?
Atentos.
Si algo ha quedado muy claro es que a Donald
Trump las reuniones con los líderes europeos
no le hacen ninguna gracia…
[¡Qué pereza tener que reunirse con toda
esa gente… Pobre Trump, sí al menos fueran
tan divertidos como Vladimir Putin o Kim Jong
Un… sería otra cosa]
El caso amigos es que el choque entre la Administración
estadounidense y la mayoría de gobiernos
europeos se extiende a prácticamente todas
las cuestiones: economía, comercio, inmigración…
y también defensa.
Veréis, el presidente de Estados Unidos lleva
años criticando a la OTAN por la supuesta
falta de implicación de los socios europeos.
De hecho, el presidente norteamericano ya
decía cosas así hace casi 20 años.
("Estados Unidos no tiene un interés vital
en Europa.
Sus conflictos no valen vidas estadounidenses.
Alejarse de Europa ahorraría millones de
dólares anuales a este país.
El costo de estacionar las tropas de la OTAN
en Europa es enorme”.
Donald Trump, año 2000)
Claro que, un momento, no se trata solo del
inquilino de la Casa Blanca.
Lo cierto es que en las últimas décadas
algunas diferencias entre los europeos y los
estadounidenses se han hecho muy grandes.
Ahí está, por ejemplo, el béisbol frente
al fútbol, el aprecio por los coches con
motores gigantescos [Cómo se nota que la
gasolina es mucho más barata] o, también,
la forma de ver las armas… en todos los
campos… incluido el de la defensa.
Sí, el ejército y la cuestión militar son
temas muy, pero que muy destacados en la política
de los Estados Unidos…
Sin embargo en Europa… digamos que no tanto…
bueno, ¿qué digo no tanto?
Ni siquiera son temas de primera línea y
desde luego no son nada populares.
(Tal vez por eso, desde que se terminó la
guerra fría, el gasto militar de los países
europeos que pertenecen a la OTAN se ha desplomado
en términos de PIB; pasando de algo más
del 3% a menos del 1,5.
En Europa el gasto militar no vende.
Y esto, amigos, es algo que ha enojado muchísimo
a los políticos de Washington en los últimos años.
Y ojo, en esta cuestión no hablamos sólo
de Donald Trump, sino también de Barack Obama o George W. Bush.)
Aquí en VisualPolitik, en un video anterior
ya os contamos porque no era tan buena idea
que los países europeos gastaran más dinero
en armas
Pero, pero.. un momento….
¿Y si en Washington tuvieran razón?
Atentos
¿Y SI WASHINGTON TUVIERA RAZÓN?
Os hago una pregunta y como siempre no vale mirar en Google.
¿Sabeis cuantos soldados tienen en total
los países europeos de la OTAN?
Pues, aproximadamente 1.800.000 soldados.
Sin embargo, de este número apenas el 30%
podrían desplegarse en caso de conflicto…
y tan solo entre 50.000 y 100.000 podrían
desplegarse de forma sostenida durante un
tiempo.
Y es que, amigos, en general, los ejércitos
europeos tienen muchos problemas operativos.
Sí, gastan mucho dinero… pero digamos que
a sus gobiernos, a la mayoría de ellos, no
les importa mucho el resultado.
Podemos, por ejemplo, echar un vistazo al
caso de Alemania, un país que en 2017 tuvo
un presupuesto militar de aproximadamente
45.000 millones de dólares.
[Es decir, es uno de los 10 países del mundo
con más presupuesto militar.]
(Pues bien, a pesar de ser uno de los países
con mayor presupuesto militar hace un par
de años un estudio de la consultora McKinsey
reveló que cerca del 60% de los aviones de
combate Eurofighter y Tornado de Alemania
así como el 80% de sus helicópteros más
modernos, no estaban preparados para el combate,
por falta de mantenimiento, actualizaciones,
suministros, etcétera, etcétera.
A finales de 2017 una investigación parlamentaria
mostró unos resultados bastante similares:
ni uno solo de los submarinos y ninguno de
los 14 aviones principales de transporte de
la fuerza área alemana estaban operativos.)
Ni uno solo.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
Incluso, un documento del Ministerio de defensa
alemán alertó que los soldados no tenían
suficientes chalecos protectores, ropa de
invierno o tiendas de campaña para participar
en alguna misión importante de la OTAN.
Y no se trata solo de Alemania… es algo
generalizado.
(Durante la guerra de Libia, a pesar de ser
un conflicto relativamente pequeño, apenas
3 semanas después de comenzar los ataques
las fuerzas aéreas europeas se empezaron
a quedar sin armamento de precisión)
En otras palabras, los gobiernos gastan dinero
en grandes programas de armamento [y en tener
contratados a muchos soldados]… pero luego
en el día a día, digamos que todo esto importa
muy poco.
Así es cómo podemos encontrarnos noticias
como esta:
(“La Legión declara la guerra sin cuartel
a la obesidad.
La unidad de élite de la infantería española
pone en marcha un plan forzoso para combatir
el sobrepeso entre sus miembros”.)
Pero, en serio esperad un momento… porque
con todo…esto no es lo peor.
Tal vez lo que más enfada a los oficiales
de los Estados Unidos son las normas, las
reglas, con las que algunos de los ejércitos
europeos han entrado en combate de la mano
de la OTAN, por ejemplo en Afganistán.
Veréis, muchos gobiernos europeos no quieren
asumir ningún tipo de riesgo, así que ordenan
a los mandos militares que mantengan a sus
soldados lejos del frente.
En el caso de la campaña afgana, por ejemplo,
no son extraños los testimonios de soldados
estadounidenses que cuentan cómo incluso
se les negó evacuación médica por parte
de los europeos porque estaban en una zona
de combate.
Atentos.
(Afganistán año 2008..
“Regresábamos de una misión cuando un
cohete impacto contra el vehículo que estaba
frente al mio.
Nuestro Humvee estaba de repente siendo atacado
por fuego de ametralladora.
De los 11 vehículos con los que entramos
a la zona de la emboscada, cuatro quedaron
inoperativos y un quinto fue destruido.
Uno de nuestros chicos había muerto y una
docena estaban heridos
Estábamos a seis horas en coche de nuestra
base, estaba oscureciendo y los talibanes
continuaban atacandonos.
Cuando llamamos para pedir una evacuación
médica, nos preguntaron si la zona de aterrizaje
aún estaba caliente.
Dijimos que sí, nos estaban atacando.
En ese momento una voz con acento extranjero
me dijo que sus reglas les impedían prestarnos
asistencia.
Me preguntó si podríamos asegurar la zona
de aterrizaje o si nos podríamos trasladar.
Los minutos pasaron a ser horas y los talibanes
siguieron disparando contra nosotros.
Entonces, de la nada, apareció una voz en
nuestra radio, era una voz estadounidense.
Un par de helicópteros Blackhawk, en una
misión totalmente distinta había escuchado
nuestra llamada de auxilio.
Los pilotos se desviaron de inmediato.
En 15 minuto aterrizaron y nuestros heridos
fueron evacuados.
Nuestros superiores nos dijeron que el país
de la OTAN que en ese momento era responsable
de las evacuaciones médicas tenía la regla
de no intervenir en zonas aún calientes.
Estábamos furiosos.
Elliot Ackerman, veterano que sirvió en Afganistán
en el Cuerpo de operaciones especiales de
los Marines.)
[Un momento, muy importante.
Tan solo en Afganistán, cerca de 900 soldados
europeos han perdido la vida.
Estamos hablando de órdenes políticas que
no se dan en todos los casos, pero que son
habituales.]
Y, no, no es una cuestión de dinero… sino
fundamentalmente de compromiso.
Los países europeos de la OTAN gastan cada
año casi 300.000 millones de dólares.
Es decir, juntos tienen el segundo mayor presupuesto
militar tras Estados Unidos.
A pesar de ello, en Washington quieren que
los países europeos de la OTAN eleven sustancialmente
su gasto militar… y es ahí donde aparece
la cifra mágica del 2% del PIB.
(EL MITO DEL 2%)
Lo ha dejado muy claro en la última cumbre
de la OTAN, Donald Trump está furioso.
Según dice la inmensa mayoría de los países
de la Alianza Atlántica están retrasados
en el pago de sus cuota.
Fijaos.
(Muchos países en la OTAN, que se espera
que defendamos, no solo están por debajo
de su compromiso actual del 2% - que es bajo
-, sino que también están atrasados desde
hace muchos años en pagos que no se han realizado.
¿Reembolsarán a los EE.UU? Donald Trump)
Pues… una de dos, o dice estas cosas porque
no tiene ni idea o simplemente lo dice porque
quiera tajada electoral… engañando, claro,
a los votantes.
Porque, seamos claros, todo esto de los pagos
atrasados no tiene ni pies ni cabeza.
(El 2% es un objetivo de gasto militar, de
cada país para su propio ejercito.
No tiene nada que ver con pagos a la OTAN
ni nada por el estilo.
Es decir, que un país gaste menos no quiere
decir que deba nada ni a la OTAN, ni a Estados
Unidos ni a nadie.)
Pero… bien, el caso es que en 2014, tras
mucha presión, Barack Obama logró el compromiso
de los países europeos de la OTAN de que
incrementarían sustancialmente su presupuesto
militar hasta rozar el 2% sobre el PIB en
el año 2024.
Y, precisamente, debido a ese compromiso,
Europa es, ojo, la región del mundo donde
más se está incrementando el gasto militar.
Fijaos.
[Sí, ya os lo pedís imaginar, luego Trump y sobre todo
sus partidarios dirán que todo esto es gracias
a él, a sus habilidades para negociar]
Sin embargo, aunque se incremente el gasto
militar… probablemente no cambie nada.
Primero, esta cifra del 2% es una cifra aleatoria,
a la que se podría llegar, simplemente, elevando
los salarios de los militares... o haciendo
trampas de todo tipo.
(Grecia, por ejemplo, es uno de los poco países
que cumple. Gasta el 2,36% de su PIB… pero
gran parte de ese presupuesto se destina a
pagar las pensiones de los militares.
E incluso la mayor parte de su inversión
en equipo militar se orienta a la defensa
contra Turquía… otro país miembro de la
OTAN.)
¿Resultado?
Aunque aparentemente se cumple la regla de
gasto… el ejército griego aporta poco o
nada a las capacidades la organización.
Pero es que incluso aunque se utilizará todo
ese dinero para mejorar realmente los ejércitos
[Y desde luego sin un compromiso político
es algo que no va ocurrir]… tampoco se conseguiría
gran cosa.
Los países europeos seguirán dependiendo
de Estados Unidos para el despliegue de sus
fuerzas… porque país a país no podrían
permitirse mantener capacidades de despliegue,
inteligencia y aprovisionamiento a nivel mundial.
Y, por supuesto, como en Europa las operaciones
militares no son algo popular, ni el compromiso
político ni las reglas para entrar en combate
cambiarían.
Es decir, tendríamos ejércitos más grandes
pero a la hora de la verdad con unas carencias
muy similares.
Pero es que, además, vamos, a ver.
Las funciones esenciales que pueden realizar
las fuerzas armadas son fundamentalmente cuatro:
Disuasión; Intervención y despliegue; ocupación
y por último ciberseguridad.
Pues para ninguna de esas tareas, el presupuesto
actual de los países europeos supone una
traba.
(Para combatir el terrorismo o para desplegarse
rápidamente en algún lugar del mundo y enfrentar
alguna situación especial no hace falta tener
uno, y otro, y otro portaaviones, es decir
fuerzas redundantes.
Es mucho más importante tener la capacidad
de desplegarse rápidamente y ser capaz de
gestionar un conflicto.)
Ahí están, por ejemplo, las últimas guerras
de Estados Unidos y la propia OTAN: Afganistán,
Irak y Libia.
En todas ellas la victoria militar fue sencilla…
pero la postguerra… un desastre absoluto.
(Haber contado con fuerzas preparadas para
gestionar los conflictos locales, las instituciones
de los diferentes países, para entrenar a
las fuerzas nacionales, no solo militares,
sino también, por ejemplo a los cuerpos de
policía o para poner marcha juzgados, prisiones
o centrales eléctricas hubiera sido, probablemente,
mucho, pero que mucho más útil.)
Al fin y al cabo, amigos, para enfrentarse
a un conflicto hace falta hacer muchas cosas…
y no todos lo mismo.
Las amenazas a las que nos enfrentamos hoy
no necesitan de más portaviones o cazabombarderos
sino sobre todo de más agilidad.
Europa no necesita gastar más, ya gasta muchísimo,
necesita gastar mejor.
Y es ahí donde aparece la idea del ejército
europeo.
PESCO ¿UN EJÉRCITO EUROPEO?
En diciembre de 2017, la Unión Europea lanzó
el programa PESCO; en castellano, Cooperación
Estructurada Permanente en materia de Defensa
¿El objetivo?
Coordinar a los países que participan en
el programa en cuanto a seguridad, adquisición
de material bélico y operaciones conjuntas
de defensa y paz.
Es decir, en otras palabras, empezar a integrar
las diferentes fuerzas armadas.
El programa todavía se encuentra en una fase
muy incipiente y no contempla como un equivalente
a un ejército europeo.
Sin embargo… está podría ser la mejor
solución a todos los problemas.
(Los 25 países que integran el programa PESCO,
integrando sus ejércitos, sus compras de
armamento, sus entrenamientos e incluso compartiendo
recursos militares podrían suponer que Europa, aún
gastando menos, tuviera un ejército moderno,
bien equipado y con una gran capacidad de
despliegue.)
Al fin y al cabo, que un país como España
se gaste una fortuna en comprar tanques Leopard 2,
que en la práctica - por falta de medios
para desplegarlos - solo sirven para defenderse
de Portugal es un gasto totalmente innecesario,
¿no os parece?
Amigos, hoy los riesgos y los retos son globales,
así que creo sinceramente que Europa necesita
más integración, hacer mejor las cosas y
en el marco de la OTAN buscar completar a
Estados Unidos… pero no gastar más.
Casi 300.000 millones de dólares al año
tienen que ser más que suficientes.
Pero ahora turno para ti ¿Crees que Europa
debe desarrollar su propio ejército?
Dejame la respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta.
Y como siempre si te ha resultado interesante
el vídeo dale a like y no olvides suscribirte
al canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.